hey what's up on today's show we talked
to a young woman who has been
triangulated into a relationship
mess between a 17 year old and her
parents what can she
do and we talked to a young woman who's
married with two little kids
and whose husband loves him some video
games and finally
we talked to an awesome young husband
who just wants to know how can i love my
wife
better stay tuned
[Applause]
hey what's up what's up this is the dr
john dolone show
we're so glad you're here i'm glad
you're here i don't know if we are but i
am the show's about you it's for you
it's your life it's your relationships
your kids
your boss all of it we're all trying to
figure out what in the world's going on
and how we're going to
re-um re-approach life
amidst the madness how we're going to
win how we're going to lose how we do
all that stuff just together right so
i'm so glad you're with us
um if you're new to our band of ninjas
here's the deal
we talk about relationships we talk
about relational iq
we talk about mental health issues we
talk about education
parenting all everything you can come up
with bring it on give us a call
my number is 1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693-3291 or you can go to
johndaloni.com
show you can fill out the form it goes
right to kelly
and she will see if we can have you on
the show
so many people write in from all over
all over the world
some people have some positive things to
say some people don't like my jokes
listen
i think i'm funny that's just what it
comes down to
i think i think i'm funny my
kids do not my wife does not most of my
friends don't think i'm very funny
i i think i am
and listen
listen this is all i got guys this is it
this is all i have
let me just have this and so if i have a
joke and i think it's funny
just help a brother out this could be
your contribution to humanity
you don't give anything to anybody
you're mean
on the internets just let me have my
jokes man because i think they're
hilarious
okay so one of the things that i hate
in the world is when i'm listening to a
podcast
and i feel like i'm in on the ground
floor and it's so good and i feel like
i'm
making a relationship with this person
and they're telling me things that i
like
and i'm trying out new things in my
world they have good people on
like for interviews and then comes that
dreaded day
[Music]
when they have a commercial when they
try to sell me something
and that drives me crazy and it makes me
think what kind of loser sucker do you
think i am
so i hate that and we're never gonna do
that on this podcast i'm never gonna
have a commercial
okay that's my commitment to you guys as
listeners i'm never gonna have a
commercial
so there i set it all right so while i'm
here i wanna talk about my new book
it's called that was me i'm just trying
to be silly i hate commercials man but
this is where i'm at i'm a terrible
salesman
i just like hey when you said that you
think you're real funny is that like
anything
yes i thought that was a good transition
joke
i'm uncomfortable selling stuff here's
the thing
um we i wrote this little pamphlet
it's a quick read it's a book and it's
got
big font in it and it really distills
all of these misconceptions they're just
straight up lies man all this drama
surrounding anxiety
and i put it in a book and we put it out
in the world
i'm not gonna lie i rolled my eyes it um
i didn't think it was anything
earth-shattering it's just stuff i've
been ranting and raving about
for years and then it sold
tens of thousands more than we thought
it would
and by we i mean me they were giving me
these numbers and projections and i
thought yeah whatever
and so i reread it here's the thing it's
a good
it's good it's good and now i'm starting
to get notes from
counselors all over the country saying
hey we're buying these in
blocks we're buying them in bulk and
we're giving them to our clients as they
leave our counseling sessions
and so we've reached a point when i am
going to
stop being all like shucks about it and
be proud about it it's 10 bucks
you can is it on our on the
johndolone.com
page yeah go to johndaloney.com you can
buy this book for 10 bucks you can buy a
whole bunch of them for 10 bucks
they're each 10 bucks but anyway um
here's the thing the book helps man
it really does folks who have reached
out to me from all over the world saying
i didn't know what was going on with my
girlfriend i didn't know what was going
on with my wife i didn't know what was
going on with my husband or my boss i
didn't know what's going on with me
and the book helps and so again i hate
commercials i i
don't want to be about selling you stuff
but at the end of the day i want my kids
to eat
and i'm not going to say something
that's crappy
and the book's doing great and folks are
letting us know that that they're being
helped by it so pick up a copy for you
and all of your friends and if you're
like me that means you're gonna pick up
three
right you're gonna pick up three copies
and that's 30 bucks
right that's a couple of cups of coffee
at whatever starbucks you're going to
all right that's it for the commercials
today buy the book it's awesome
all right let's go to um
ellie in wasilla
oh my goodness kelly help me out
alaska
i just my brain stopped i'm sorry ellie
i just screwed that up i was about to
say arkansas
but it's ar not ak right
yes correct hey that was a good joke
listen here is john's vulnerable moment
of the day
i was a high school geography teacher
if you want to know what's wrong with
the texas education system this guy
right here who doesn't even know
off the top of his head that ak is
alaska this is embarrassing
i did not get doc i'm gonna get
somebody's gonna write in and be like oh
my gosh where'd you get your
doctorates they weren't in geography
that's no excuse man my
son knows this and so i apologize ellie
and to everyone
in alaska and arkansas
let's do this ellie how can i help
hi thank you so much for taking my call
thank you for calling me and letting me
humiliate myself
what's up how can i help and i think you
are funny so there you go
yes i knew it thank you ellie you don't
even have to go to church this weekend
that was awesome appreciate that okay
sweet
um okay so i'll just shoot with one
question
my i feel as if my husband's
lifestyle and expectations don't meet
his actual current life
and um i'm not sure how to
handle that or encourage him or
enlighten him
or just i just gotta roll with it
okay so i gotta i had a story from
high school years and from me but i
i don't wanna speak into your life i
don't wanna just presume to know so
i've gotta hear what what is the
disconnect here
okay i have a feeling it's going to be
awesome ellie i just do
okay it's not super dramatic i was like
it's so super dramatic but
it's not um i'm a stay-at-home mom of
two
i have a three-year-old and a seven
month old um
and my husband works full-time i feel
like the disconnect
is where um you know
it with two little kids our time is
very much devoted to them and you know
this
with us being late or our schedule being
interrupted or um
just like or like in and health i
i guess i'm trying to figure out how
exactly how to pinpoint it but it
it's basically like i i feel like when
things don't go the way they should
it's a big deal or i get an eye roll
or like i i mean i don't know should i
just give an example
that would be awesome yeah because
you've lost me here no i've demonstrated
i'm not
i'm not the sharpest tool in the drawer
right but yeah i've lost here so help me
out
okay so i i have a husband who games
and um one evening our you know our
seventh month old is hit or miss with
sleep
and so you know i was putting her down i
come back upstairs
um because she just wasn't going down i
was like okay well this is going to be a
time where
i've got to prioritize my sleep so i've
got to get ready for bed as well
so it's like you know what i'm just
going to have to interrupt his gaming
session with his friends
and he's going to have to take over with
her while i get ready for bed and then
i'll get her right back
so how hold on how dare you
stop a video game for someone to be a
parent are you insane ellie what's going
on in
this alaska you live in yeah so but you
know how it went then so
it was just he was upset that i
couldn't have waited 10 more minutes um
then he said that um
how you know i i
you know like how could you not wait 10
more minutes full of blood then
i i said you know i just it's just a
quick minute you can at least hold her
for a little bit
i'm gonna get ready for bed and i'll be
back and then
um i said um
i'm trying to think he said something
anyway so he said something and i had
had enough i was exhausted and i said
honestly babe i could care less
and he said i know you don't give a crap
except he didn't use crap
and then um rolled his eyes and
stormed off and was really mad and it
just
so give me you know give me another um
uh dudes who prioritize video games over
their family
is one of the few things on earth that
makes my soul rage
and so give me something else because i
want to love your husband
i want to love him okay so another thing
um saturdays are usually like our family
day and we
it took us a long time to establish that
and make that important so
it's been a couple years now where we've
established that so then
he was saying that he wanted to go take
the dogs on a walk um
i told him hey can we all go with the
family he's like yeah let's do that
and then um you know as obviously it
takes
it's winter so it takes a while to
bundle up kids and all that and it just
like
he gets upset that it's taking so long
and then he says this is [ __ ] um
why can't we he's like this is [ __ ]
how long it takes until i'm like
no what's ridiculous is you know
we have two children this is our life
now like it's like this is just
the way things are this is just the
season that we're going through and it
just feels like
things like that or like like he goes to
bed super late and he
tries to sleep into the last second i
just feel like i'm trying to juggle
everything on my own
and i don't know i just
it just sounds like you're you've got
three kids at home right
yeah it does yeah so um before i go
further i wanna let you know
um the next time he uses that word to
describe somebody i want you to
hit him in the mouth with a closed fist
okay
okay um i've spent my career working
with folks
with all sorts of um challenges and
disabilities and so that's not a word i
tolerate in my life or in my sphere
and so i want you to hit him in the
mouth and say that's from a dude in
tennessee
okay okay don't let anybody use that
word in your sphere
um so here backing out
um there is a yeah there's a clear
disconnect
of between you're not a high school kid
anymore who happens to have money and
happens to have a home but you're a dad
of two little kids and then here's what
this looks like right
so i could spend this call beating him
up and i don't want to do that
um he's not the only guy on planet earth
he's not the only mom on planet earth
who's
has yet to wrap their head around what
actually being a dad entails what
actually being a mom entails and
how that does not a matter of dragging
your own
your old life into this new life your
kids aren't a part of your old life
you got to build something totally new
right
from the floor and so the only person in
this situation you can control is you
right you hear me say that all the time
and what i want you to do is to propose
a like a where are we going
conversation with him i would have
somebody i don't
i don't know if they travel by reindeer
i don't know how you would get somebody
to come watch your kids but i want you
to get somebody to watch your kids and i
want you all to go somewhere
but you have to have a conversation
you've got to have a
um i'm struggling with
your inability to love us and your
inability to prioritize us over your
video games and over your precious
schedule
and not in a fight way not in a late at
night way
the fact that you can't say the fact
that you have to say the words i don't
care about your video game
and that hurts his feelings is tells me
y'all are not on the same page
the the good thing here for you is this
is not uncommon for folks with young
kids
okay um your body has
taken the brunt of this your heart mind
and soul has taken the brunt of this
and so you've been acutely aware of how
everything's changed and he hasn't okay
so i want you to bring him along that
conversation i also want you to
recognize
um in his head
he is putting in a lot of hard work
wherever he's going off to work
and that in his head i'm i'm pulling my
end of the bargain here yeah what we're
asking couples to do now is something
they've
never been asked to do before in the
history of the world which is
connect and complete each other
and co-parent and co-help and
co whatever with all of these digital
distractions all this is new
and so start from a good place here's
what i'm worried about i'm worried about
ellie you starting to resent him
and resentment is the death of a
relationship right
it's hard to come back from resentment
it's hard to come back from counting i
did this
what have you done right so if you were
to sit down and talk to him and say
i i am struggling with you not wanting
to be here i'm feeling
second class to video games i'm feeling
second class
to your precious schedule and i don't
want our children to grow up feeling
like they're a burden to you
just because it takes a long time to put
a coat on it on an 18 month old right
that's a nightmare putting on clothes on
a child right
um what's he gonna say what's his
response gonna be
tell me he's a good guy that hasn't
thought about it that way and he's gonna
hear it
he might not be yeah well i mean i think
he will have a
a better understanding if it's like
separate from everything else because i
think maybe he'll understand the
maybe the gravity of it because i've had
these conversations
but it's been in our home so you know
sometimes they're cut short or something
like that because
a child wakes up but um i think it'll
it'll click better and i i think it's
i mean he is he is a good guy
it's just i feel like he said i just
feel like he's
he's having a hard time just accepting
the new norm
and so let's approach him as though he
has a tool kit
and he's trying to drywall a house and
all he has in that toolkit is a hammer
and a chisel and a screwdriver and what
he
desperately needs in that tool kit is
some sandpaper
and a trowel right and so he's gonna
need some new tools
that's gonna start with you and him
learning some new tools on how you talk
to one another so i want you to practice
i want you to do this one thing
um i want you to ask him start talking
in language what's your picture for
today have you heard me talk about that
before on the show
no i don't think so okay so one of the
biggest challenges that i find with
relationships with couples is
they they think in pictures but they
speak in words
and what does that mean here's a quick
example um
i you tell him hey tonight honey we're
gonna go on a date
and you flutter your eyes and you just
say and it's gonna be
hot and he goes awesome so all day he's
just in his head just going like
hot date hot date hot date what is she
going to be wearing for how long
not very long this thing's going to end
what hotel are we going to end up
staying at
right and in your mind you know that the
alaskan taco barn please tell me they
sell tacos in alaska
the alaska taco barn is having jalapeno
taco night
for three for a dollar and you are gonna
have six of them and you're gonna have
super gas you're gonna be in bed by 10
o'clock right
and so he loves tacos too and you love
rendezvous dates
but you both used the word date and you
both had a different picture and so you
pass each other and then you both end up
upset at the other one
um and it goes into this dance oh my
gosh how can we never end up
filling the blank and why is he never
satisfied it go in all of it because
you use the same words and not the same
pictures so what me and my wife do
every single day and we've had to
practice this for years is
we ask one another hey what's your
picture of today look like
in that way he can say hey this is a
really busy day
and i really want to connect with my
buddies tonight and
since we live in alaska which is
essentially mars i
we connect play in that silly silly
video game and i know it's lame but
that's how we connect with one another
and it's monday nights and we do it
every monday night and then you will
know
i'm gonna have to lean into the monday
night thing
and on the back end of that you're gonna
say tuesday wednesday thursday
i can't limit the dates well you what
you want to do is invite
no i mean like limit the days that he
plays video games like i can actually
write that because well here's what's
happening video games has become a drink
it's become uh somebody another woman
he's texting on his phone
it's become cocaine it's become extra
work it's becoming a way he distracts
himself from
the yelling and screaming and chaos that
is a life with kids
right and going on a walk clears your
head going on a walk with a little kid
does not
it makes it worse right and so i deal
with the same thing with my daughter i'm
walking out the door i'm gonna go ride
my bike and she
says can i go on a bike ride with you i
instantly know there's no exercise gonna
happen here i'm gonna go
one quarter of the length and she's
gonna be yelling and wanting me to carry
her home and i have to ride home with
her and a bike in my hand it's you know
what i'm saying so
it all changes and there's a spirit of
flexibility that goes with that but that
comes after that's a tool that's
something you learn it's something you
step up and do
that starts with hey what's our picture
for this week look like
how are we gonna be here together i love
the fact you want to connect with your
buddies and if it's as goofy as playing
video games go get them right go get it
but i need you on tuesday wednesday
thursday and friday to be fully present
here
and that's when you're able to say my
week looks like about tuesday or
wednesday
i'm ready to set my whole house on fire
and i really need you to come home and
lean into the kids
and come thursday friday right so that's
when you start having those
what does the picture of this week look
like and if you can change that
i don't know a lot of folks that's not
true i know many but
often folks will lean into it because
it's just been a matter of
they screwed up the language they've
just screwed their language up and i
want to approach your husband as
though he's a great guy who just doesn't
have the right tools and he can learn
this stuff
right and that comes with having a
conversation that you're going to lean
in together
and you be vulnerable too by the way you
be vulnerable too
um you've got to learn to speak your
mind and he's got to learn to hear it
right and both people um have some
growing to do
but i gotta know man if he comes back
and he's like no no way lady ellie i
play video games i'm a gamer
it's on right then then you're gonna
have another problem call me back and
i'd love to have that conversation
i love talking to some gamers man um i
actually thought this call
and now i'm not talking to you anymore
ellie but i'm talking to james and kelly
i thought this call
back in high school i used to dress like
i was a metal guy like i was so hard i'd
like
let my hair grow and i didn't bathe and
i was like yeah yeah
cool medal and then my dad one day was
like
you're like a super poser john i was
like no i'm not and he's like you don't
do
drugs you don't do this or this or that
like you're not that cool man
and it was so deflating but so true i
just remember being like oh
so i thought she was gonna tell me he's
like dressed up in biker gear or
something but he wasn't a biker but no
he's just a gaming dad so
all right let's go to michelle in
pensacola florida
michelle what's up hey
dr dalony thank you so much for taking
my call thank you for calling how are
you
i'm doing great i'm just looking for
some advice all right bring it on let's
do it
all right so my husband and i our
current
family while my husband completes
military training
okay our family that we're staying with
they have a 17 year old daughter
who has come to both me and my husband
with uh she's telling us that she's got
some depression
and that she needs help however one
parent
is indifferent about the situation while
the other
seems to be resistant because we're
being told that she finds it
embarrassing that her daughter needs
help
so my husband and i we don't know what
to do because
you know daughters underage we're
staying with family they're you know
gracious for letting us stay in their
home
and we don't know what to do without
crossing the line but making sure that
we get this girl help
yeah yikes man talk about not by your
hand but in your lap so
um when she comes to you and says she's
got depression
walk me through that and what i'm
getting at is number one
overarching everything i'll make sure
she's safe she's not gonna hurt herself
she is not
in a abusive situation so when she says
i'm not
um i've got depression i need help what
does she mean by that
so she's she's seeking help and from a
therapist or
that's the main thing that it seems like
that she's wanting um however she has
told my husband and i
that she's had thoughts of doing
something just to get herself committed
so that she could do
or could get help and we both feel that
she
is not going to do anything to herself
just because we've made ourselves
there for her and she comes to us to
talk when she's having really bad days
um but it's gotten to the point where
she has
mentioned doing something just to get
herself the help that she's needing
because her parents aren't signing off
on
you know any type of therapy or anything
like that
and walk me back to the conversation
you've had is this
is this your family or your husband's
family
it's my husband's family okay so walk me
back to a conversation you've had with
one of the family members that said i'm
just embarrassed
the the embarrassment side of it is
coming from
this is what the daughter is telling us
and
there has like there was actually an
incident today where
i know that the daughter had
to somebody her mom was there and her
mom refuses to let her talk to somebody
alone her mom
makes sure that she is there but once
they all got home i know that the
parents were arguing
and i don't know what about but there's
definitely some conflict
there so that's kind of you know we're
hearing one thing from the daughter
kind of seeing something going on on the
other side but we don't know how to
approach it with
the parents either so this is a pretty
clear-cut moment
and um this is a moment when you're
gonna get to
do a lot of good with some very simple
actions okay
so um as as grown up as 17
feels and is articulate and smart
and um on top of things as a 17 year old
can
can be i've worked with 17 year olds my
whole career um
they're children they're kids okay
and so how they experience and feel
things is not always accurate
and in fact sometimes it can be way
distorted
between what they're feeling and
experiencing and hearing and reality
and what it doesn't appear
at the outset that she has had is a
place where she could sit down and be
safe with somebody and tell them hey i
need some support and help
and so what you're gonna do is model for
her what that looks like
and you and or your husband are gonna
let her know
that um she is that you're going to help
her get help but that help starts with
her
parents and you are going to have a
sit-down conversation with her parents
about your concerns about her mental
health
about her suggesting that she might hurt
herself
just to get some support and care and
that
you are going to leave it up to mom and
dad to lean in and get some help
but that if um that you will be happy to
help
along the way and if mom and dad don't
get help then you're going to make that
call to her school and the school's
gonna lean in and get her the support
that she needs
okay you've been triangulated into a
mess is what's happened
okay and you are probably cool
and you are probably beautiful and
you're probably
um hip and this 17 year old looks up to
you
and thinks your husband is cool because
he's an army guy now and
y'all are probably showing her more
attention
than she's been shown in a long time and
she has dragged you guys into them
into a um a mess of a triangle if you
will between her and her parents
and what you have to do is to break that
triangle immediately get out of that
mess
she's asked for help i'm gonna get it
and that help starts with mom and dad
and if mom and dad are part of the
problem then you call the school and the
school will
lean in and get her the support and care
that she needs whether it's with a
school psychologist or counselor
whether it's calling in a school social
worker if there's abuse or things like
that going on
but you need to signal i'm going to
model what an adult does an adult gets
professionals involved adult gets a
parent involved
and an adult does not get dragged
underwater by a 17 year old
okay and what that will do is that will
free you up
she might get mad at you she might think
oh my gosh you ratted on me i hate you i
can't believe you
and then she will at some point come
around to understand that you cared
about her more than
anybody else did at this moment in her
life and she will love you
for the rest of her life for caring for
her okay
okay but more um more
deep conversations and uh deep
conversations with
late teens are the best and the worst
they feel so good because they're so
rich
and they feel so empowering to both of
you because you feel so good that
someone's trusting you with all this
stuff
and she feels so good that an adult is
hearing her
and you got to get her with
professionals and with their parents
that's just the way that is so go for
that i'm interested in how that
conversation goes with mom and dad
so give me a shout back i'd love to hear
how it goes and by the way we are
getting folks who are um
sitting in emails letting us know how
things go and we'll have a um
i'll be rolling some of those out as as
we move the show on in the next couple
of weeks
um some of them are fascinating some of
them are great um actually all of them
have been great no one's called me and
been like you screwed my family up
uh i'm sure i'll get that at some point
but not yet all right um
so really quick i get a lot of questions
about a comment i made once about being
addicted to
anxiety about being addicted to stress
and there's a biochemical addiction here
there's a default setting here
um i was recently coaching a couple and
i had them do this here's what i mean
when i say
addicted to anxiety um when you are
anxious when that part of your brain
kicks off your fight or flight or freeze
response it floods your body with all
sorts of chemicals all sorts of hormones
and um the most common one we hear is
adrenaline
we hear cortisol those things
rev you up right they get you ready to
take off sprinting they get you ready to
fight and i'm simplifying this as
as as simple as we can here right and
sometimes they just lock your body up
you just
straight freeze there are seasons where
when you start to get well when you go
take medication and they just shut that
alarm system
off or you start a you start sleeping
and you start getting a group of people
you can interact with
most people think if i just take away
the anxiety alarms i'm going to be well
and the reality is you end up being
hollow there ends up being nothing there
and what we will you have to learn new
behaviors right
new ways of handling because bears are
always going to show up there's always
going to be tigers
walking into your life then you've got
to start finding positive ways to deal
with some of this stuff and some of it
is recognition some of its information
some of it's blowing it off some of it's
now i got people i can call whatever it
looks like but
when you grow up with a steady stream
of these hormones running through your
body
these chemicals running through your
body coursing through you all the time
when they're off you begin to feel a
little bit amiss
something's not right something is going
to get me at any moment
and what we end up doing is creating
situations where
our bodies can get their chemical fix
where we will put ourselves in
situations or create chaos
or not give ourselves like a clean room
or a clean truck
or drive the speed limit we'll do these
things that are small they look
so inconsequential but they continue
pumping that those stress hormones
through our body
and over time you get addicted to
anxiety you get addicted to that stress
we all know folks who um
when things are going well they just
start creating chaos and some folks
thrive in it when things get messy this
is the story of my life
when things get bananas right i'm in an
active shooter situation i am in
dealing with a massive crisis for some
for some reason everything slows down so
it's way down i get real calm i get real
rational i get real responsive really
quick
it's the nights when things are going
well my marriage is good my kids are
doing well
that i have one weird thought or i'll
see one weird thing while scrolling on
the on stupid internets
and then bam my head locks into it
starts spinning
starts coursing that stuff through my
veins and now i'm up and at them and now
i'm not gonna eat and i'm not gonna
sleep and i start spinning and spinning
and spinning
and there's something familiar about it
there's something yep there it is that's
the real me
and what we have to do is break that
addiction to anxiety
so when you start working towards
turning those anxiety alarms off when
you start sleeping being intentional
about sleep and eating well and getting
a community and moving your body
and finding work that has purpose to it
that matters to you
when you start doing those things the
alarms start going off
and then that's when you start
practicing gratitude that's when you
start practicing
looking for beauty start practicing
laughter start practicing joy
start practicing discipline and suddenly
over time those become your default
settings
now it feels weird when i wake up if i
don't go
exercise i feel off all day because my
body is used to that it used to wake up
and look for things that were on fire it
doesn't do that anymore
now it looks for i gotta go move now it
looks for hey let's go have a meditation
time
it starts looking for those things that
are gonna be positive right so
um look in your body i i was
i was just saying a second ago i was
working with a couple this weekend
and what i had them do was say something
vulnerable to each other they had to say
the following
i'm being vulnerable here and here's
something you don't know
that i love about you and they had to
say that to the other person and then
they had to say
i'm being vulnerable and here's
something about you that i don't like
and you don't know it and had to say
that and so as they started to speak it
what i would do is tell them to freeze
and then i looked at the recipient of
the thing that they didn't like
and i'd say what's going on right now in
your body and one of them said my
heart's racing
like and i can feel it in my hands like
she's about to tell me something that
is going to hurt and then the other
person said
like my stomach just dropped while they
were waiting for it and what i'm trying
to get him to do is to identify that
feeling
because that ends up being our default
feeling and if we don't have that
feeling then we don't feel like we're in
control we
once you identify that feeling then you
can start leaning out of the addiction
to anxiety
and start coming up with some better
responsive behaviors and if
their anxiety alarms are called for i
hope they go off if an actual tiger
shows up
they should go off right if we have
people storming the capital if we have
cities on fire if we if we have whatever
hurricanes whatever
your anxiety alarms should go off right
but you don't want them to
you don't get addicted to it all right
so let's take one more call let's go to
sean in boise idaho
see i knew that one guys i knew idaho
sean i had a screw up earlier so
i'm back though i'm back in action so
what's up brother how can i help
okay hi yeah thank you so much for
taking my call thanks for calling man
yeah i'm so i was calling because my
wife has a very low
self-esteem and i'm just trying to
figure out
a way that i could help her see her
value more
oh man that's an awesome question that's
an awesome question
so walk me through it give me an example
of what this looks like have you tried
to help in the past
talk me through it yeah so she's
always having negative thoughts about
herself um
she says things like she doesn't think
people care about her because
she's not worth it
says she's afraid that i'm going to find
someone else that's better than her i'm
going to leave her
where does that co where does that come
from sean
um i don't know like did she get that
from her mom she get that from her dad
she get that from some high school
boyfriend
where does that negative self-talk come
from where did she learn that
um probably from her parents um
that i think she has what you refer to
as a neglect
trauma okay um her dad was
very um uh
controlling and had a bad temper
and her mom she couldn't go to her for
anything because she
her mom couldn't handle anything
emotionally
so so she got messaging both
affirmatively and neglectfully that she
didn't really matter
yeah she wasn't very important she was
in the way and
mom can't even deal with you dad's
annoyed by you that's angered by you
and so um your value
is little to none right
yeah okay yeah i think everything leads
back to that
okay so then sexy sean shows up on the
scene
that was a straight up rap lyric right
there that was some alliteration if i've
seen it sexy sean shows up on the scene
you all fall in love you get married and
then what
um so um
yeah so we've been married for well i've
known her for 15 years
okay we've been married for 12. and
um has this been an arc of your entire
relationship
um yeah it seems like yeah from the very
beginning she
see kind of didn't understand why i
would
like her because she thought that she
was not um not good enough yeah
what do you tell her when she says
things like that
um i try to tell her uh
that's not true that um she says things
like
that i don't love her but i try to tell
her how i
how i actually feel um
i try to sometimes i just try to
hold her or hug her and um
show her other kind of um like give her
gifts sometimes and
and sometimes she feels okay
uh for a moment she believes in for a
moment and then
um a few days later she goes back to the
to the negative thinking okay has she um
been in and out of therapy for 14 years
or 15 years
um no she hasn't really been in therapy
at all okay
okay so um there
my guess is this there's a lot here
i will give you a one particular
scenario that may or may not be
right um but it may be not entirely
accurate but i think i'm pretty darn
close
okay you ready yeah
there were two people if it all goes
down
the apocalypse is upon us there are two
people
who are supposed to hold your hand and
put their hand on your face
and tell you that i love you and i am in
this with you until it's all over
and that's the mom and dad of a precious
little girl
yeah and her mom and dad did the
it all came down in whatever not really
apocalypse in their house but
in their imaginary house apocalypse it
all came down and one parent said i
can't even deal with you
and the other parent raised his voice
and or his hands
and said this is because of you
and imprinted on this young beautiful
little girl at a young age was you are
in the freaking way
by the two people who when it all when
all the smoke cleared
should still be standing by here they
let her know
the smoke's your fault and so
at an early age she took on an identity
of a burden
she took on identity of somebody who is
unlovable
and that's how she keeps controlling her
world
okay okay over time
this is how she keeps herself from
getting hurt this is how she controls
you
so instead of saying hey i really just
want to hug tonight
can we just have a night of hugging
instead of affirmatively asking for it
because she may have done that as a kid
and mom said i can't deal with you
so instead of doing that the way she
gets her hugs is by saying nobody loves
me
i don't even know why you love me why
don't you just leave you're gonna leave
anyway
and then you come and hug her right so
she gets what she wants
but in the process she's drowning you
right
right so i'm going to say this
she's going to have to choose that she
wants a different identity
one that is not as we in the nerd world
we call it the one down position
where she maintains control of your over
your entire house
underneath the boat by saying she's just
controlling the boat from underneath it
by saying nobody loves me
and everyone's got to stop with her
doing and respond to her right
and what she's going to have to decide
to do is she doesn't like being in the
water anymore
she wants to be on top of the boat she
wants to be on the land she wants to be
in a really nice home with the people
who love her
and that she's worth being loved and she
is gonna her voice is gonna matter
and she's gonna be able to say hey sean
tonight's hug night
and i don't want you to do anything but
focus on me because i'm awesome
and you're gonna be like sweet i'm sexy
sean
on the scene and you're gonna show up
right
so it's twofold number one she's gonna
have to decide that
after a lifetime of running
sometimes often folks need professional
help there
to help them make that transition from
you are worthless
to your parents sucked and you are
of value here's a guy who has dedicated
his life to you
and you are going to learn new ways of
communicating to one another
does that make sense yeah so sean
what i want you to do is i want you to
lead the way
and i want you to let her know that you
are going to
um start seeing a counselor there in
boise idaho
and i want you to let her know that you
love her so much you're going to learn
you're going to invest in learning some
new skills some new ways that you can
teach her
how valuable and how much you love her
and you want to grow
as a guy who is in love with a young
lady
and i want you to encourage her to go
with you she probably won't or she may
say something like oh because you think
i'm screwed up and broken too
and your answer to that will be no no i
want you
to see the same beautiful wonderful
lovely young lady that i see and
i'm right because you are beautiful and
lovely and wonderful
and you don't see it and so i want i
would love for you to go
with me and we're gonna learn some new
skills so that you can see her too and i
can learn new skills on how to love her
even deeper and better than i already do
unfortunately you're not gonna be able
to force her to do this
and sometimes your action is gonna even
actually make it worse
oh you're going to therapy that must
mean that like fill in the blank
at the end of the day she's gonna have
to decide
that she's worth being well she's gonna
have to decide that she is worth being
loved
and man something about being truly
connected with somebody else
in a loving relationship starts a
healing process
then you can start practicing new skills
then you can start approaching the world
head high face first instead of butt
first right with negativity negativity
you don't love me you don't want me
everything's bad everything's gray and
it starts with that decision
you can't control that you can't control
you brother
so i want to applaud you for being a
husband who wants to help
the way you can help right now is
leading by example the way you can help
right now
is by inviting her not forcing
manipulating or anything you can invite
her in
and then you start the healing process
for yourself because here's the other
part
you've been told for 14 years or 13
years that the way you love isn't enough
and so whether you know it or not sean
you've got trauma too brother
and so i want you to go and start
getting well too
um i want you to start your own healing
journey and again invite her invite her
invite her
we need more guys like you sean i
appreciate you man all right so as i
wrap up today's show let's do this one
i got a couple today you know what i'm
gonna go with this one
and all my cool metal friends out there
i'm a punk rock dudes i love this minor
threat song dude we can listen to some
bad brains
nope we're gonna listen to some like
slayer pantera
nope we're going all the way back to
1995.
to a guy with acoustic guitar a drummer
saxophone player a violinist and a bass
player that listened to nirvana
the guy was so sure of himself he just
named the whole band after
his first and last name dave matthews
under the table in dreaming the song
satellite goes like this
satellite in my eyes like a diamond in
the sky how i wonder
satellite strung from the moon and the
world your balloon
peeping tom for the mother station
winter's cold
spring races and the calm away by the
storm is chasing
everything good needs replacing look up
look down look all around
hey satellite
who's the king of your satellite castle
dave matthews dropping poetry
on the dr john deloney's show
[Music]
you